(upbeat music)
- So whenever my mom goes to Nigeria,
I always have her bring
me back some prints
because it makes me feel closer to home
and I just love to mix African prints.
I think there's nothing like it.
- This dress is my mother's.
She got it in the 80's.
She was my age when she lived in Senegal.
Every time I wear something
connected to my culture,
it feels right and it feels like
what I want to do every day, honestly.
- I bought everything that
I'm wearing from 125th Street,
but African print has always been in
because it comes straight
from the mother land
and if you don't know,
you better ask somebody.
- I'm wearing an African print style today
to represent my culture.
I grew up in Kenyan culture my whole life.
- I'm celebrating my
mother-f***ing heritage,
and I am happy to be wearing it today.
- [Guest] Wow, that's
my design. I made it.
My mom sold African print for 35 years,
so that was the only
thing I knew the most.
That's how I showed how different I was.
- My outfit is from East Africa,
more specifically, Tanzania.
- [Guest] Too often we forget
we're really coming from Africa.
We still have all this
culture ingrained in us.
- Wearing these types of styles helps me
feel like I am a little bit closer to home
even though I live here, I
have another home in Tanzania.
- Yes, it makes me feel
connected to my heritage.
It's loud. It's proud.
It's brilliant.
- It's like being able to have
a little bit of home everywhere I go.
- Even if you're born
here, first generation,
second, third generation,
you should always make sure
that you're connected to your heritage,
- [Third Guest] because in order
to know where you're going,
you must know where you come from.
And wearing these prints and
collectively understanding
the story and the messaging
behind the prints,
understanding the significance
of representing our culture,
representing our continent.
(upbeat music)